dans ces ateliers on travaille le bois
ces ébénistes et menuisiers sont
spécialisés dans l'agencement de luxe du
salon à la cuisine ce boudoir par
exemple prendra bientôt place dans un
bâtiment classé en tout 25 salariés avec
leur propre spécialité là le vernissage
ici la coupe mardi ils ont été
récompensés de leur travail le label
Entreprise du Patrimoine Vivant leur a
été remis et ce n'est pas qu'un simple
diplôme on ne compte dans les Yvelines
que 12 entreprises labellisé 1130 au
niveau de l'Hexagone une grande fierté
pour tout le personnel une grande fierté
d'être à côté de grand nom euh
d'entreprisees centenair reconnu
mondialement donc oui on peut être fier
pour obtenir ce label Jean-Marie a dû
prouver que son entreprise faisait
partie de l'excellence française trois
critères détenir un patrimoine
économique spécifique comme des outils
par exemple avoir une certaine notoriété
et enfin faire preuve d'un savoir-faire
rare et pour le chef d'atelier ce
dernier critère et leur point fort on
arrive à travailler avec plein de bois
différents avec un savoir-faire aussi
assez particulier quand même et puis et
puis on a aussi le personnel qui va bien
avec on a des gens très compétents à
l'atelier qui font des belles choses et
qui ont l'amour de leur métier depuis 5
ans l'entreprise comprend un bureau
d'étude qui met en relation les plans de
tous les acteurs des chantiers et suit
les projets jusqu'à la pause un atout
qui leur a permis de gagner des marchés
80 % du chiffre d'affa est réalisé à
l'étranger vers les États-Unis le
Moyen-Orient et l'Europe et ce label
devrait leur ouvrir d'autres
opportunités le premier bénéfice escomté
c'est en terme d'image évidemment pour
se différencier des autres fournisseurs
notamment sur les marchés
internationaux et puis l'état
effectivement soutient ses entreprises
par un crédit d'impôt sur les dépenses
affectées aux recherches développement
de nouveaux produits nouvelles
prestations un deuxème crédit d'impôt
leur sera octroyé pour la apprentissage
2200 € par an et par
apprentis